Speaker 1: I don't want to spend a ton of
time on this, but it is important just to
follow up with some of these things.
You might remember that when Cassidy Hutchinson
of the WHO worked with Mark Meadows, Trump's
former chief of staff, when Cassidy Hutchinson
testified before the January six committee
and made a number of different explosive claims
about Donald Trump and Secret Service and
all of these different things.
There were anecdotally messages, statements
from Secret Service saying that's not true
and we're willing to testify under oath.
And the January six committee said, great,
come in and testify under oath.
And then they didn't.
Why haven't they done it?
Well, we have to sort of speculate a little
bit, but here is Adam Kinzinger, one of the
few Republicans on the January six committee
saying we haven't been able to talk to them.
I mean, listen, they said they said we'll
talk to you and they just don't come in.
Speaker 2: So we want answers to that.
We heard through anonymous sources in the
media that the Secret Service agents present
when Cassidy Hutchison talked about the heated
argument in the limo, the president's beasts,
that they were eager to talk to us.
We haven't been able to talk to them yet either.
We have our doors wide open.
They just have to do it under oath so that
on top of again, we just have a lot of people
coming forward with pieces of the puzzle,
maybe pieces of information, maybe Cassidy
Hutchison or Sarah MATTHEWS inspired them.
And so we're going to work on beginning to
write our report, but keep this investigation
wide open and getting more and more information.
Speaker 1: So, listen, they all came forward.
A bunch of them came forward and they said,
we're willing to testify.
Secret Service agent reportedly willing to
testify.
Trump did not lunged at him.
This is from The Guardian.
And this was right after the testimony of
Cassidy Hutchinson and then a bunch of different
other media outlets reported on this.
CNN and other outlets reported the pushback
on the alleged Secret Service incident from
Tony or Nadeau, also a deputy chief of staff
in the Trump White House, Robert Engle, Trump's
security chief, and on and on and on.
And the committee members said, we welcome
you to be here under oath, of course.
And really, Cassidy Hutchinson was under oath.
What is the value of Secret Service agents
showing up not under oath and refuting the
claims?
Let's get everybody under oath.
So then we can actually say we have conflicting
under oath statements.
We continue to have only one set of claims
made under oath.
And of course, it wasn't surprising to me.
I've been tweeting about it for weeks.
They haven't testified.
Why haven't they testified?
We don't know.
They're law enforcement.
One would think they don't have an issue in
principle with being under oath.
But if you won't testify under oath about
the things you saw while working for the Secret
Service.
To me, that's a red flag.
And of course, in courts of law, we don't
consider people's silence as indicative of
guilt.
But when you come out and you say, we'll testify,
we'll talk about it, we didn't see what Cassidy
Hutchinson said and then you're welcomed.
Great show up, take an oath, just like she
did, and tell us what you saw.
And then they're missing.
It is completely reasonable in the court of
public opinion to say maybe they weren't telling
the truth and maybe Cassidy Hutchinson is.
One other note on the Cassidy Hutchinson testimony.
Pat Cipollone, the former White House counsel
in his under oath testimony, he didn't dispute
the things that Cassidy Hutchinson said with
some he claimed privilege, attorney client
privilege with Donald Trump.
With some he did a sort of I don't recall
or I can't necessarily speak to that.
But he went under oath and didn't refute any
of the things that Cassidy Hutchinson said.
So still waiting for the Secret Service agents
to come in.
Not surprising that they haven't, and I don't
expect them to follow me on Twitter at David
Pakman.
Let me know what you make of the latest absence
of secret.
Service agents who were just weeks ago so
ready to testify.
The David Pakman Show is a viewer and listener
supported program.
Please consider yourselves invited to sign
up at Join Pack MSN.com.
We do an extra show every single day for our
members called The Bonus Show.
We also offer a commercial free audio and
video feed of the show every day to our members,
including making it available five or 6 hours
earlier than the show is published to everybody
else.
And you also get priority access to David
Pakman show townhalls like the one we are
holding tonight, July 26th at 6 p.m. Eastern.
I hope to see many of you there.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com.